hi guys it's silver at and as you might
know I'm kind of sick at the moment and
I'm not really capable to do any
commentary so I've got a couple of
people to help me do this today joining
me are PewDiePie and say hello PewDiePie
hello though that was not pewdiepie and
other people oh you're not even gonna
say that you this time as young also the
Jew yeah whoa whoa see that's why I
shouldn't record when I have a call no
he always acts like this no seriously
one [ __ ] and i'm already voice cracking
like that mm-hmm let's get your stretch
hey hmm the point i should not do that
when I'm recorded i well I was going to
make a American house today because
because America is the best house we oh
i remember this house it's the house
that you kept on changing for like an
hour oh but that's that's every single
building for me in one second three ever
Oh like this one especially like inside
the other ones were like maybe you ought
to the roof this one you like almost
completely destroyed and then started
yep well I started it to be fair and
then I started with two floors but then
I of course we didn't realize that
Anning is wanted at third my warring
men's adding another floor so I ended up
having four floors and for an American
house that doesn't really seem to make
too much sense oh I think that's the
jamboree text yourself it definitely
should Chris can you stop reading this
call Oh wanna makes it makes it fun they
make it makes it more fun yeah you
didn't join us when no one here join me
when I rated panda so now and we have to
make the harder it are you oh you poor
thing I'm getting this vibes that this
is I'm going to be that one skype
episode but never again oh this is the
part where I destroyed
house oh my god her prey I think the
cold off to something who was the host
every effort but he got dropped I think
wasn't on the Jew the host I think so
I'll Jubal coming up those pesky max my
internet crashed i'm sorry okay um yeah
well the Americans internet crashed
because the 18-year can work on posts I
won't have comcast they have optimum
whatever its American oh if you guys
would watch my shitty a channel the link
will be in the description everybody is
gonna click that like what if I is it at
the link and like labor when what link
is that's like the way my is some lake
to the random screwing or something oh
you want high quality or Haiti sweet
videos if you want mediocre roller
coaster simulator videos subscribe to my
channel Polly curse the city no I'm
honest I want to [ __ ] off his
popularity that's why everyone is in the
call I mean we're all close friends of
his exactly friends we are close friends
we're good people yes we are all good
Beatles and silts Silva's a nice guy
trying to help us out hmm yo let's not
nice people tonight to be fair i've
known you since 2012 09 more likely
2000-2014 2k for bracelet i think this
is the right moment to bring that up
standing ovation [ __ ] oh oh god I
remember this this was me trying to pick
the right picket fence and it just
didn't work [ __ ] god you were just
bitching about every picket beds just
like I'm not really a fan of that one
what don't you ever have that a roller
coaster go three where you're looking
through objects and like every single
is that every single object this is just
not what you want to be only one who has
that issue because you're a
perfectionist oh I'm certain I'm not I
have anything to and then was this
building i'm in yay nothing guys you're
me is no life you play what's hey wait
be honest with me what's the opinion on
like a show up Chris what's the opinion
all night the modern glossy stuff with
the classical stuff because not too soon
about it it looks like very like it
looks fairly you're here well I'm not
even sure that's a compliment or not
brown matter of opinion needs more pound
shrubbery multirow not to give Andrew
Brown shrubbery supports can be better
but good layout now that just seems like
the the standard comment when you watch
like a terrible roller coaster but you
don't want to be negative about it
you'll like it but good good layout yeah
that's an interesting concept you have
there hey so so for it uh house I Asian
part going of elements I've Asian sets
available on the five asian sets
available i thought the one I don't know
if leaders like Wes than ten that you
can use we must including the asian
sensation has no one made us Japanese
and Asian sets am I the only one who's
bothered by the fact that it's called
asian sensation and it just was like 49
[ __ ] and it sounds like a porno I think
I think Mike did that time oh damn it
Mike we all thought it was so mature but
secretly and and and people are
complaining about my any window well
asian sensation people hey it could be
worse you could name your one of your
new rides Sylvain
nah I'm gonna do that it's actually
sylvanas but everybody's making a joke
out of it like who the silliness I think
we need to have a son quote unquote
commentary new you guys have anything to
add um blueberry got back to my chin see
teeth or not promoting anybody's channel
here we are going berry yeah I'll see
you guys in the Oct three shenanigans in
which I actually allow this to happen oh
so you're gonna make that series
eventually it's gonna happen it's
confirmed after after all these years
it's finally going to happen indeed but
yeah let's at this video so on thanks
for watching and let's play thank you